The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
All right, Steph.
Let's go into Claudia
Goldin and Lawrence Katz.
STEPH: Obviously,
Goldin and Katz
focus on the big
picture issue, which
is what you have drawn for
us in the big picture--
pun semi-intended.
And a consideration
that I had was
on the research and development
process, which is not something
that they touched on
here, which could maybe
provide a short-term fix.
And I'd love to hear your input.
Is there, in the research
and development process,
people who openly talk about the
ways in which their technology
may cause social disruption?
And if so, can you
identify someone
on a project that
you've worked on
or a firm that
you know of that's
concerned about the social
or economic implications
of the technologies
that they are building?
RASHID: Don't VCs do
this all the time?
They decide--
MARTIN: No, they don't.
[LAUGHTER]
RASHID: But they might
decide, this is my niche,
this is what I
haven't seen before,
and these are the reasons why
this particular technology
would take advantage
of this unseen market.
And so I don't
know if that's what
you're trying to get at with--
MARTIN: No.
I think her point was
like, OK, if we do this,
it will change society this way.
Like Uber said,
OK, if we do this,
this technology will get rid
of all these cab drivers,
and there's going to
be a social disruption.
Is that your kind of angle?
STEPH: Sort of, yeah.
MARTIN: OK.
Yeah.
I think your angle
was more like,
oh, this is going
to be a huge hit,
and it's really going to
change society, right?
RASHID: Yes.
MARTIN: OK, cool.
STEPH: Right, so I guess in
my consideration of business
and consumer markets, and
in some of the research
that I'm conducting for my paper
on autonomous vehicles, one
of the questions
that I've been tasked
to ask by
anthropologists, two firms
that I might be
interviewing, or even
as I'm going over literature
base and public releases
to the press, is
essentially, who on the staff
is in charge of answering
questions or raising
considerations about
social disruption
or economic disruption that
your technology might cause?
And if a firm can't answer that,
then you have your answer--
that they're not--
that they don't consider that
as a part of their research
and development process.
And I think it's possible
that some people would argue
that that's beyond the scope of
what the firm should be doing,
right?
They should be focusing
on the technology.
They perhaps should not have
an ethicist that they should--
or perhaps they should
just have an ethicist
that they consult
with, but it should not
be someone who's formally
a part of their staff.
So I'd love to hear
your perspective on this
as perhaps a short-term fix.
As we sort of promote
technological advances,
should there be someone who's
constantly raising a flag
and saying, ha, perhaps this
might not be a good idea
to deploy in the time frame
that we have set for ourselves?
SPEAKER 1: So I'm working on the
mobility of the future project
as part of my thesis.
And so a lot of it is
with autonomous vehicles.
And it does seem--
well, first of all, with
that example specifically,
a lot of the companies
who are working on it
are very secretive about
what they're doing.
So it's not very
clear as to what's
going on within the companies.
But outside of them, at
least with this example,
there is a lot of
work and awareness
about potential disruptions.
I question whether that's
always been the case or kind
of the recent disruptions
have spurred people
to think about this more.
So there's a group
at the MIT AgeLab,
I don't know if
you've talked to them.
STEPH: The what lab?
SPEAKER 1: AgeLab?
Age.
STEPH: Age?
Like, A-G-E?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARTIN: What do they do?
SPEAKER 1: Well, they do
a lot of stuff related
to how people are aging.
But they also have
a big group that's
working on the
autonomous vehicles,
less so on the technology side,
but how it's affecting people.
So they have a
lot of experiments
where they're letting
people drive autonomous cars
and recording them
with their consent,
and they're trying to get
knowledge about how people are
interacting with these
technologies, what
changes it could have, what
negative changes it could have.
So they showed us a video of
this guy who was looking down
at his phone for
like two minutes
while driving on the Mass
Pike, which is terrifying.
And so as we transition from
a not quite autonomous vehicle
to a fully one, he
was talking about how
he expects to see more
accidents in the near future,
until we get to the point.
So I think people are
thinking about how
these technologies
and their developments
affect things other
than just how we're
getting from place to place.
It's not such a simple story.
STEPH: And would you
mind elaborating?
The reason I bring up
this point, and why
I've been thinking
about it so fully,
is because Bill assessed that
a very important component
of driverless vehicles
is the impact that it's
going to have on the
workforce, on truck drivers,
and on delivery laborers.
Do you think that those are
considerations that have been
raised vis-รก-vis
driverless cars?
And do you think that there
is maybe a role for someone
to be highlighting that as an
issue within each innovation
team?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I feel like that hasn't been
as much of a focus in our work.
People talk about
it, but no one really
talks about-- they're like,
that's going to be a problem.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's the end
of the discussion
from what I've seen so far.
But I do think that,
especially after this election,
people are talking more and more
about disruptive technologies.
I hadn't heard people
talk about it much.
But then I was
listening to a podcast
today where someone was like,
I noticed in Logan the movie--
CHLOE: I was just
about to bring that up.
Oh my gosh.
SPEAKER 2: Wait, if
you spoil it, I swear--
SPEAKER 1: I haven't seen it.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: I haven't seen it.
MARTIN: Cover your ears.
STEPH: Me either.
SPEAKER 1: In the movie
Logan, apparently--
I haven't seen it, you
might do a better job
describing-- but there's
a scene where there's
all these trucks around.
And none of them have
cabs, because they're
driving themselves.
And there was a senator
talking about this.
And she's like, wow,
this really could happen.
And then what happens to
all of these truck drivers?
I never thought about
it until I saw Logan.
So I think that's interesting
how it's permeating through--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I
want to hold this discussion
until next week's class, which
is about the future of work.
I mean, it's exactly like--
it's about this problem.
So we've gotten it on the table.
Everybody's going to have
a chance to think about it.
SPEAKER 1: Watch Logan.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And you
can go back and watch Logan.
You can recount your
favorite stories.
But, Steph, do
bring this up again
when we go after these
issues next week.
But focus us more now on
Katz and Goldin and Bamol,
if you would.
STEPH: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Thank you.
STEPH: I have been redirected.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm not
trying to silence you, Steph.
STEPH: No, no, absolutely not.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I promise
you airtime in the next class.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPH: Well, I think--
I guess one of my critiques of
my social science education--
and I think this is generally
my critique of social science
education generally--
is that there are benefits
to talking about an issue,
but there's only so much that
public discourse can get you,
especially in a
round table setting,
in an academic environment,
where the most of us
start to feel like,
for the most part,
are on the same
side of an issue.
So I struggle to come
up with good questions
and think about what might
actually be meaningful,
as we're having a conversation
about an issue as large and as
difficult to grapple with
as inequality, especially
as Katz and Goldin purported.
But I think one of
you talked about how,
relative to Bamol's analysis,
if America should shift
towards a focus on primarily
promoting breakthrough
innovations, where we can still
maintain competitive advantages
in the research and
development system
rather than even
concerning ourselves
at all with the fixing
of the education system
or the fixing of
the R&D pipeline.
And this sort of hints
at a question that Matt
had asked earlier in the
semester, where he said,
is the impetus on us, as a civil
society, to educate everyone?
Is that even advantageous to us?
Do people even want
to be educated?
And what are the benefits?
And making this resource
available to all,
when it seems like
we're already failing
spectacularly at this
experiment that is
the United States of America.
MARTIN: I don't
think we're failing.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
MARTIN: It's 300 years old,
and that's relatively short.
We're still figuring our stuff
out, in terms of nations,
right?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, I'd
say we did pretty well.
We're not great, not anymore.
But-- so let's make
it great again.
[LAUGHS]
MARTIN: I think it's kind
of like bubble thinking,
like people losing their
minds in sensationalism.
I think it's more like--
because their argument's
pretty much like--
it's like saying,
oh, yeah, we have
a McDonald's, everything's
set up to do McDonald's.
But look at Chipotle.
How do we make McDonald's, the
burger, be Chipotle, right?
It's like you really
can't change one system
to a whole new one.
What you do is you have
to make Chipotle, and then
make Chipotle a poppin' chain.
[LAUGHTER]
You have to go and
make the next system--
SPEAKER 2: Poppin'?
MARTIN: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm going
to use this metaphor, Martin.
It's good.
MARTIN: I mean, because
people are freaking out.
It's like, this hamburger
just can't be a burrito.
And I'm like, why?
Well, the whole
infrastructure is
made to make hamburgers, right?
STEPH: Well, see, and I think
that at the heart of what
you're saying, to sort of
elucidate where I'm coming
from in asking this
question, there
is an education professor who
I grew close to during my time
at Wellesley, who in his
first year of his PhD program,
his advisor posed to everyone,
if you had the option,
would you blow up the education
system and start again
or would you change
it incrementally?
And his answer was blow
it up and start over.
But we don't have that option.
We don't have the privilege
of bringing in the Chipotles
and then seeing if
they work, and then
adopting all the McDonald's
to suit that consumer market,
right?
We very much recognize
that students are humans
and that humans have a very
particular ethic consideration
than do technologies or
other kinds of research
and development projects.
So if we are to meet
the kinds of goals
that Goldin and Katz
and Bamol and Freeman
are advocating for in
improving our education system,
how do we deal with the fact
that these are human lives
with whom we are experimenting?
MARTIN: I think
it's a good point,
but I'm not talking about that.
What I'm trying to
say is like, what
are we defining as education?
Are we defining
education as I want
people to know math and science
really well to communicate it,
to think innovatively in it?
Or are we defining it as
like, we're going to get out
of a four-year college, right?
So I think a lot
this argument is,
the current infrastructure
or the relationship
for the last 100 years
has been colleges.
So we define education
as graduating a college.
But if you make it as, I want
to make the best, most educated
person with all my
tools right now,
and being able to import
them into society well,
in terms of into
jobs really well,
how would we make
that ideal system?
You start making that system.
And it's not going to
change overnight, right?
You don't grow up two years
old and the next day you're--
I mean, there is the
movie 13 Going on 30,
but it's very rare, right?
[LAUGHTER]
So I think it's you start
making the new system
and you kind of
start to pour over.
There's a whole
issue with trying
to change a current system,
because they're already
playing--
well, this happens with
later, mature markets.
What happens is there's going
to be three or four or five
players, right?
So when we talk
about institutions,
we have Harvard, MIT, Stanford.
They're trying to fight
against each other,
because they don't want to--
it's hard to be different
when we have to compete
against someone like that.
And so they have to
play their games.
The reason an innovator can come
in is because they don't have
to play that
keeping-up-with-the-Joneses
games.
That's my point.
SPEAKER 2: You're throwing
out a lot of metaphors.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPH: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE],, Chipotle--
[LAUGHTER]
LILY: 13 Going on 30.
MARTIN: So there's a whole
book on communication
where it's like, if you make--
I could explain it in
a super technical way,
but you're not going to get it.
And I can say
something like that,
and you'll be like, OK, kind of.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, we're--
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN: The other thing is
that you won't forget it,
because it's so out there,
that you're like, OK, OK--
SPEAKER 1: Chipotle.
MARTIN: You guys are going
to remember the three
points, right?
SPEAKER 2: Well, no.
I remember that Chipotle versus
McDonald's was discussed.
I don't know--
MARTIN: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, you know,
let me say something
here too, which
is that we are going to dig into
the textbook reading on legacy
sectors, because
there's no question,
but education, and higher
education in particular,
are legacy systems.
And the whole issue of
how do you bring change
into legacy systems is kind
of an underlying theme here.
So I'm glad we're right
at the brink of trying
to figure this out.
I guess I would posit that the
meaning of Freeman's reading
for us, I think, was that there
are real economic consequences
to your leadership in the
science and engineering talent
base.
And that Katz and Goldin take
us to kind of a next step
and enable us to address a
larger set of societal problems
and tie it significantly
to the education system.
In other words,
the growing problem
of the polarization
of our society
and the growing
income inequality
in our society that will affect
the quality of the democracy,
and probably already is, that's
very much tied to these curves
here and what portion
of the population
we're moving onto
that upward technology
curve and what portion
of the population
we're leaving behind.
That's the meaning of that
crossover point in the 1970s.
And what are the policies
that would really
address trying to
get those lines back
into parallel, right?
Because that seems to
be a pretty important
societal problem.
So Freeman identifies a
set of economic issues
that draw us to be
concerned with the science
and engineering talent base.
And Katz and Goldin
tell us, by the way,
there are very deep
societal well-being
problems that are tied to
the education system as well.
And then Bamol points
to us and says,
by the way, these folks are
studying the higher education
system, but that's not
the only route here.
We have to understand
this other dimension
if you want to
introduce innovation
into the overall economy.
Education for
incremental advance
is probably not the only system
we ought to be worried about.
And that's kind of what
Steph's round of questions
here was driving at, I think,
if I've interpreted you right,
which is what is that
more disruptive education
system that we have
to contemplate here
if we want to educate not
only for incremental advance,
but for true innovation as well?
Is that fair?
Sort of.
STEPH: Yeah.
I think if I were to have one
last maybe point or question,
I would ask if any of you read--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, why don't you
make some key
points in your mind
about what these pieces mean.
You just heard my version, but--
STEPH: Yeah.
So I guess I last started
off with a straw poll.
As you know, I favor these.
How many of you have heard or
read Pedagogy of the Oppressed
by Paulo Freire?
Do you know what pedagogy means?
LILY: Maybe Martin can
explain it to us with--
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm going
to rely on Lily for this one.
STEPH: Yeah.
So was there anyone who had
read Pedagogy of the Oppressed?
Have any of you
ever taken a course
in education, education policy?
How many of you have
very strong feelings--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Except
for this course, of course.
STEPH: Except for this course.
How many of you feel like you're
stakeholders in a conversation
about the change in national
education policy or in state
education policy?
SPEAKER 2: OK, I think
we found something.
STEPH: OK.
Who feels like they're a
stakeholder in the education
policy realm?
SPEAKER 2: I mean, don't we all?
MARTIN: A stake stakeholder
or active stakeholder?
STEPH: Like an
active stakeholder,
like you're willing to show up
to Congress, to go to protests,
to talk to legislators,
blah, blah blah, blah, blah.
I mean, that kind of
highlights, to me,
the divide between
the kinds of stuff
that Goldin, Katz, Bamol,
Freemen, et cetera,
are talking about.
And this is, again,
hinting at my issues
with the way in which we
teach social sciences.
That so much of the Socratic
method, which is essentially
Bill explaining to us
what it is that we read
and then having us
flesh it out and debate
in a lively and analogical way.
The Socratic method
is to get us thinking
about what this means
truly in implementation
and how to grapple with theory.
RASHID: I think,
yeah, as you start
bringing that up, it might have
been maybe instructive for us
to have a couple of readings
by a couple of states who
are grappling with
education issues
and grappling with some
issues, particularly those that
are like, I am the
lead administrator,
I'm in charge of the education
for maybe the city of Chicago
versus the state of Illinois,
and how they're actually
going about grappling with
these public institutions trying
to change these things.
Because it's really
nice to kind of look
at the macroscopic
level and be like,
OK, we're not graduating
enough [INAUDIBLE] science
and engineers.
But in reality,
education, as we said,
because we have this really
distributed model in the US
compared to Sweden,
it's like, I'm
looking at this not only
community college by community
college, but state by state.
And that's how folks sort of
interact with these education
issues.
And I think maybe
to Steph's point
and what I'm trying to
get from her is like,
you have these active
stakeholders that are really
involved in their
small pools and might
have a little bit more of an
effect or a lot more ideas
on how to innovate
within their small pools
to get to this
state where we want
breakthrough
education in addition
to incremental advances.
And so I think my
recommendation would be,
is there someone maybe in this
Pedagogy of the Oppressed book
they could offer an
alternative opinion.
Are there folks who do
education professionally
and who do educational
administration-- do
they have these same
thoughts and are they worried
about these same things?
And are they trying to
look at these problems
at the same level?
STEPH: And are their
opinions-- and I
think this is a
crucial point for me--
are their opinions respected?
Because a PhD from the Stanford
Graduate School of Education
or the Harvard Graduate
School of Education
does not mean the same
things to most people
as a PhD in material science
from those same institutions.
And that concerns me, right?
Because if it's
the individuals--
there's also, I guess, an
undercurrent in education,
and we have mentioned it before
in this class, of those who
can do, those who can't teach.
And it is that sort
of point of disrespect
that we got at at the
beginning of class
that I think merits far more
consideration by this group
than do perhaps the contents
of the economics readings
by Romer.
Because if we, ourselves,
are not convinced
that teaching is a
worthwhile profession
and that the education
of young people
is a worthwhile activity, then
who can be convinced of that
if we are involved and
invested in the promotion
of more equitable education
of science and technology?
Because we know
that that's the key
to driving economic
growth, and also prosperity
and decreasing inequality.
And so that's why
to me, when Bill
says that Goldin and Katz
are talking about what
are the policies that would
address us getting back
to a more equitable
economic system, to me
it's not about policies,
it's about culture.
It's about our perceptions
of other people
and what they are
doing with their lives
and about our distancing
of ourselves as,
but that's not my issue,
that's not my problem, right?
So I think it's unfair and
a little bit intellectually
irresponsible of us to claim
that distance while also
critiquing it.
So I would posit
to all of you that,
if you have time in the next
maybe two or three years
to pick up this book, Pedagogy
of the Oppressed by Freire--
MARTIN: What's the book about?
STEPH: It's about the
education system in Brazil
and about the ways in which
students have been disregarded
by the system and conceived
of as passive recipients
of knowledge rather
than as active learners.
And the metaphor
that he utilizes
is that they're receptacles,
and that we dump in knowledge,
and then we expect them
to regurgitate it out
and to be able to
apply it in the field.
Where as his
understanding of pedagogy,
which is the study of teaching
and the study of learning,
is that individuals have
to grapple with something.
And that's sort of
at the heart of what
Lily will be talking
about in the MITx reading,
when they start talking
about Seymour Papert, who
was a brilliant professor and
researcher at MIT who created
the field of constructionism,
which is the study of something
by doing the something.
And that is actually
being very widely adopted
in Southeast Asia in countries
like Singapore and Thailand,
who are experiencing
momentous economic advances
in the research and
development sector.
So I think very much
pedagogy and considerations
of culture become
really relevant
when we talk about education.
LILY: Well, I think we
need to get back to dollars
here, though.
Because if you're head of
household, single parent,
or single-income family--
who in here thinks that you
can have a family on a K
through 12 teacher's salary?
You can't.
And even if you're--
yes, the average K through
12 teacher salary is higher
in, say, Los Angeles than it
is in central Illinois or rural
parts of the US, so they
compensate for living expenses,
but you still cannot be single
parent head of household on K
through 12 salary.
So sure, you can think
that K through 12 education
needs to be reformed, you can
be passionate about teaching.
But if you are financially
responsible for a family unit,
you can't be a teacher
in K through 12.
It doesn't matter how
much you care about it.
MARTIN: There's a part from
the reading that was like--
I think they needed 50 hours
to get a $1,000 or something
like that [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I'll
tell you what I'm going to do.
I'm going to push us, so
we can get out of here
at a reasonable time level.
I'm going to do the last
reading from our textbook,
and then come back
to the MITx reading.
MARTIN: Yeah, we need
more graphics, Bill,
because all these
have been so great.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I figured
I'd put myself up here.
MARTIN: Did you get Michael
[INAUDIBLE] to do it?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I had to
really struggle with this,
Martin, I can tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
So, look, here's
what's different.
So new technology
innovations are
very slow to enter
legacy sectors, right?
Remember discussing energy?
We invented fire--
I don't know how many
millions of years that took.
Then, we burned trees.
We did that for a millenia.
RASHID: I think the word
invented was hastily used.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN: Discovered.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Shall we
say lightning struck, right?
And we moved to coal, right?
Moved to coal, and
then we moved to oil.
And that's about as far as
we've gotten, essentially,
since that time.
SPEAKER 2: I mean,
the rate of adoption
has increased exponentially.
So I think we're doing OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yes, compared to wood.
MARTIN: The population,
too, has gone up.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So similarly,
another legacy sector,
higher education.
What was the last really
big reform in education?
So we went from--
STEPH: Allowing
women to participate.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
that was an advance.
There's no question about it.
But we had the platonic
academy, and then
a momentous breakthrough
around 1500 years later--
we came up with the book.
That was clearly a
great breakthrough.
That's, from a
technological advance
period, that's about it,
until we finally figured out
how to use this kind of stuff.
And we're starting to figure
out how to bring that IT
revolution into the classroom.
So that presents-- if the
issue is bringing change
into this system,
technology, obviously,
can be a change driver.
And that's an interesting story.
That's not the only
change and reform story,
as you just pointed out, Steph.
There's other important changes
that have to be considered.
But really, within the
last five, six years,
we've actually seen the
entry of IT-type tools
into the classroom setting with
potential momentous change.
So there's an open question
here about whether MOOCs
and online education are going
to be a disruptive innovation
and whether they will
disrupt higher education
and substitute--
in effect, create a new model.
Is this a Chipotle replaces
McDonald's kind of approach?
See, I told you I'd still
hear your metaphor, Martin.
And how will higher
education respond?
Will it respond with
a blended model?
Or will it attempt to
keep its existing model?
So we'll talk about
that for a minute.
As we've seen, universities
present a deep problem
for this kind of
disruption, because they
are legacy sectors.
And like all legacy
sectors, they
tended to resist
disruptive change.
Institutions of higher
education conduct
almost no R&D on
education itself--
almost none.
It's astonishing.
The services sector,
generally, are not
particularly good at
this, but higher education
may lead the pack.
There are very
perverse pricing issues
in higher education, as
you all are paying tuition
at the moment understand.
It's a very decentralized model.
It's very hard to spread
change and spread new ideas,
to transition new
ideas, because this
is a very decentralized system.
In legacy sector terms, there's
a collective action problem.
How do you get collective action
across literally thousands
of institutions?
And I'm just focused on higher
education at this point.
There's a whole additional
story for online
and the K through 12 sector.
What's happened?
You all are familiar with edX,
the entry of a nonprofit model
here.
And frankly, I have to
give tremendous credit
to Rafael Reif, because I
never thought universities
themselves would originate
potentially disruptive changes
for themselves.
That kind of
violates my rule set.
But Rafael basically,
personally,
drove a fair amount of this.
And his background-- he
was a poor kid growing up
in Venezuela and from a family
that had not sent children
to college.
And he managed to get to
go to the technical college
in Venezuela.
It was a real
breakthrough for him.
And ends up at MIT through
a series of miracles
and becomes president.
And he thinks all the
time about that community
that he left behind.
I know from knowing him
and conversations with him
just how he saw this
online education
model as a remarkable
new tool to get
education and educational
platforms everywhere.
I mean, it is a remarkable
new entrant possibility
in education.
And he did this, frankly.
He drove the creation of edX.
And there were
corresponding examples
coming out of Stanford
Udacity and Coursera
in a comparable period.
But he wanted to do
a nonprofit model,
because he thought it would be
better-geared to this mission
of significantly improving
education everywhere,
that a new tool set
would be at hand.
Suppose kids like him growing
up on sandlot baseball
lots in Venezuela could have had
access to MIT courses, right?
What would that be like?
So that was his story,
and that's the story
behind the creation of edX.
And the nonprofit model enables
certain kinds of things.
A for-profit model
enables other things.
But one of the interesting
features of edX
is that it is an
open-source model.
It's an open-source
technology platform.
And people contribute
and constantly build up
the quality of the
technology behind the model.
It's harder to do that in a
for-profit kind of approach.
It's still finding its way
towards a business model,
and we'll talk about it.
The other major MOOC
providers are listed here.
You're familiar with them.
They're on for-profit models.
The political world took
a look at these MOOCs
and had different
ideological reactions.
On the right, to
some extent, they
saw an opportunity of these
free online educational courses
as an opportunity to get
rid of these pesky left-wing
universities that are constantly
training the wrong people.
On the left, there was a
sense that, oh, we can finally
get rid of tuition, have the
Bernie Sanders free tuition
dream, because online education
doesn't cost anything,
and we'll just do that.
Obviously, that's a little
bit of magical thinking here
on both sides.
But states have
begun passing laws,
doing things like
requiring $10,000 BAs
and comparable kinds of issues.
But the deep question
here is, what's
going to happen to the
residential campus?
Is online just going to
displace this whole thing?
And if not, why not?
So online, I think as
all of you understand,
it can do some
things really well.
It's a whole new tool
set for visualization,
for representation.
It offers incredible
opportunities
for reinforcement and assessment
that a lecture can't do.
You can use feedback
loops and repetition
to do continuous
assessment, which there's
no way your standard college
and university lecture class can
ever replicate those
kinds of capabilities,
and they're pretty important.
So online is going to have
some features that are better
than what lectures can do.
And then, potentially, if
you move the lecture online,
then you can free
up your classroom
for much more interchange
and interpersonal kinds
of communication and
more of the learning
by doing opportunities
that Steph was suggesting.
So maybe it frees up what
the classroom could become.
Now, vital educational
elements remain face-to-face.
At least at the moment,
online can't replicate these.
So oral expression,
oral presentation,
advocacy skills,
the way in which
you have to organize
your expertise
to be able to speak
about a subject area--
face-to-face can do this.
It's really hard to do that
effectively, at this point,
with the technology online.
Written analysis-- so far,
online writing evaluation
leaves a lot to be desired.
Research-- look, in
the end, you really
do research on lab
benches with colleagues.
It's still quite face-to-face.
And you can replicate some
of that through simulation
and modeling, but a
lot of it you can't.
So there's a lot that
probably needs to stay
on the face-to-face side.
So these kinds of skills.
Learning requires a lot of
human scaffolding for discourse,
argumentation, mentoring,
for making the case,
for research, for making
the conceptual leap.
And a lot of what occurs in the
classroom, the socialization
process of the classroom
drives a lot of learning--
the kind of back and forth,
the kind of competition,
the kind of connections
between people,
friendships that build, the kind
of community feeling of a class
comes together.
Those are very
powerful learning aids.
These are very powerful
learning tools.
And obviously, you
can't get that stuff
sitting in a basement in
front of a blue screen.
So the real question
here is, how do you
optimize the two sides?
How do we let online
do what it does best?
And how do we let the
face-to-face piece thrive
and do more?
That's really the
opportunity that we now
have, is to completely
restructure education
with a whole new tool
set that, in turn, will
enable that face-to-face
education to kind of rise
to a new level.
That's the dream.
That's the hope.
That's the reform this
potentially enables.
So it's a human machine
symbiosis, remember?
It's JCR Licklider.
Let the computer do what
it's good, and let people
do what they're good at, and
you have a symbiosis of the two.
That's what we could
get in education now.
That's the opportunity space.
And that's a blended
learning model.
Now, the technology
is going to change,
and it's going to get better
at some of these things.
But that's an ongoing
and extended process.
What happens to the university?
For a long time,
newspaper journalists
were writing
articles, oh, ha, ha,
what's going to
happen to universities
is what happened to
us as journalists.
All our newspapers went out of
business essentially, right?
Ha, ha.
It's going to happen
to you too, see?
This online revolution is
going to drive you under.
It's problematic if we
do that, because frankly,
universities create
the course content.
They are fairly important
institutions, after all,
on the content side.
They're research engines as
well as teaching centers,
so we kind of need that
research in the American system
and many other countries.
We blend the research model
and the teaching model,
so that there's
a lot of learning
by doing, more so in the
graduate education phase,
but there's a lot of learning
by doing in that system.
So you need these
institutions for that stuff.
And if you use the model to
drive the university model
under, you've got these
underlying really deep kind
of problems.
So there's a question
about whether or not
universities will adapt.
And part of that story is
bringing learning science
to online education,
and we're going
to get to that in just a minute.
The online revolution
does create
incredible opportunities.
We talked earlier
about the possibility
of worldwide availability
of high-quality education.
It's not a blended model,
but it's pretty good.
It's pretty good material.
You can learn a lot from it.
That's a staggering new
opportunity for education
worldwide.
And that's precisely why
Rafael Reif pushed this effort.
That was the vision
that he saw, frankly.
Martin?
MARTIN: OK.
So the US probably won't
do a DARPA for education.
But I was thinking a lot,
especially when talking
with this about JCR Licklider--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Mm-hmm.
MARTIN: Is that right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
MARTIN: I always want
to say Licklicker.
[LAUGHTER]
So what if they did a
little special institute
that just focuses exactly
on what the vision is?
Because JCR focused
a lot on the vision
of what ARPANET would
be, so the vision
in an ideal education world.
Which I know they have
that as an initiative,
but have that DARPA intensity
with project managers
and moving initiatives forward.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I mean,
it's an interesting idea.
And there was
discussion of creating
a DARPA within the
Department of Education.
I have to say, I was skeptical
about whether that could work,
because there's no
real tradition of R&D
in the Department of Education.
It's really quite limited.
And would they understand
the model enough?
Interestingly,
today-- or yesterday--
DARPA issued a broad
area announcement for,
you guessed it, develop
a learning machine
for lifelong education.
That's the challenge, right?
So DARPA is now
in this territory
in some very interesting ways.
And actually, the military
is in this territory.
The military has done more than
any other organization by far
to use computer gaming as
a training tool, right?
And computer gaming, as you
all understand probably a lot
better than I do, operates on
an education kind of model.
In other words, learning that
game is a very complex process
and is acquired over time.
And a good game
gets that flow right
of helping introduce the new
elements of the game to you
and the learning that the game
requires in manageable steps,
and then reinforcing
that and reiterating
or put you back in the feedback
loops so that you get it,
and then driving you to
the next stage of the game.
That's a very interesting
potential educational tool.
Probably some of the best
work in the country that's
being done on that is
being done by Eric Klopfer
here at MIT, who's developed
a whole new set of education
games for K through 12.
I'm surprised that industry
hasn't moved in on the sector.
I think it's gradually
starting to happen.
But that's an interesting
part of this story,
because the only story
here is not MOOCs.
MOOCs came about because a
whole bunch of computer nerds
at places like MIT and
Stanford saw, wait a minute,
we got broadband
around the world.
We have a whole new
delivery mechanism.
We've got a whole new tool set.
Let's do something.
And they rushed
to fill that void.
And edX was created by folks
out of our computer science
department.
Rashid?
Go ahead.
RASHID: Yeah.
So it might be instructive--
I'm going to go from
past to present.
But it might be instructive
to take a look at,
when we figured out the
printing press was a thing
and we could mass
print books, who
was the one who decided
how do we change maybe
from a Socratic
teacher-student-apprentice
relationship to teacher and
then large lecture hall?
What were the
driving initiatives?
Or who started with
these large lecture
halls and these same maybe
Licklider-based vision
for how is education going to
look once I have a textbook?
And so now, how is--
you need the same people
to start taking a look at,
how is education going to look
in this blended learning model?
And I don't know--
even if MIT or Stanford
and all these people
have any sort of idea
of what that vision
for that blended
learning model is.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, I think
we're starting to look at it
in a pretty serious way here
and a number of other
places, as well.
Good intellectual
work is ongoing.
Let me close off with a
couple of points about this.
And let's be sure to
hold on to your question,
because I think it'll be
particularly relevant when
we talk about the learning
science piece too, Rashid.
One thing that we're
learning about these MOOCs
is, how many people
want to go and sit
in front of blue screens
in their basement
and take a one-off course?
MARTIN: Bill Gates.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Maybe Bill Gates.
[LAUGHTER]
I have to confess
that I probably
came to college because I
wanted the degree, right?
That's probably why I took
all those courses in the end.
I wanted something
that would translate
into economic gain for me.
That's obviously a
profound motivator.
So platforms that
are organized simply
around offering one-off courses
without a coherent framework,
without a resulting
credential, that's
not a very good economic model.
So the MOOC offerers had
been very much moving
in the direction
of trying to find
some kind of certificate
that will certify that you've
accomplished something.
So a lot of people will be
just interested in content.
And I've certainly
taken MOOC courses
just because I was
intrigued with the content.
But a lot of people
are going to be
motivated by that credential.
And MOOCs are moving
in the direction
of offering credentials
for completing things.
I mean, Georgia Tech and
Udacity have a master's degree
in computer science
now, which is available
online at a remarkably
reasonable price-- far
low in class, on
campus tuition levels.
MIT is, in a very
innovative way,
doing these mini
master's courses.
I think we did one in an
area MIT is famous for,
which is supply
chain management.
And there's several
more to come.
The D-Lab has just picked one
up or the world development
community is doing one.
There's going to be more at MIT.
That's a very interesting model.
You get a, quote, "micro
master's certificate"
for completing the course.
And you pay, because there's
got to be assessment,
and that costs.
Somebody has got to
do that assessment,
so that's going to be a cost.
So you pay a modest amount
for that assessment,
and you take a year-long
micro master's course.
And then MIT, if you've
done really well--
MIT will accept you for
a semester on campus.
Now, they can only offer
that to a modest number
of the thousands of people that
are getting the micro master's
degree.
But interestingly,
other universities
now, once you complete the
MIT micro master's piece,
they are enabling
you to come on campus
and get a real
master's in the course
of an additional
semester of work.
So that's a very
interesting model.
That's obviously much
more of a blended model.
You get a lot of
content and information,
which online is pretty
good at on the online side.
And then you really come in
for an intensive classroom
experience, which is much more
the way in which they designed
the micro master's here.
When you do the
real master's, it's
much more learning by doing.
Steph?
STEPH: Well, I
just wanted to note
that a similar model exists at
the Harvard Extension School,
except it's obviously in person.
The extension school is
perceived as a back door
into Harvard in the
same way that you
can take one-off courses at
MIT if you talk to a professor
and they approve you.
So there's lots
of opportunities,
I think, to take a look at
Harvard's extension school
model to think about how
blended learning might happen.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And MIT used to
have an extension
school in its early days, called
the Lowell Institute, which
is essentially an
adult education
program that was available
for citizens in Boston--
very innovative and interesting,
on its old historic campus,
right across the
river in Back Bay.
Somehow that got
lost in the process.
But in a way, MIT has just
opened a whole new school.
That's MITx.
And it's a massive--
MARTIN: It's very global.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --worldwide
global extension school.
So there's a whole
new school here.
We just haven't fully
recognized it yet.
And, look, lifelong learning
may be the best application.
Because in lifelong
learning, in theory at least,
you've already learned
those explanatory skills,
those oral presentation skills.
You've already learned
those writing skills.
You've already got a lot of
those fundamental pieces, which
are largely a part of the
undergraduate education scene,
but also part of the
high school scene.
In theory, you've got
some of those down.
And then what you're in
for, after doing work
in a relevant area, you're in
to enhance your career or skill
set in a lifelong
learning setting.
The average age of a student
at a community college is 29.
In other words, they're
already in the workforce.
40% of what community
colleges now offer
are certificates in
quasi-professional areas
that, in effect, certify
to employers that you've
got an additional skill set.
That's very interesting, that
lifelong learning opportunity
to upgrade your skill
set and qualify, for you,
a new set of career areas.
That's a really
important feature.
important problem
for those people who got left
behind through this failure
of our higher education system
to graduate enough people.
That's a really interesting,
promising option
for what online
can help us with.
And lifelong learning
may be the best tool
we've got that MOOCs and
online education can apply to.
So those are some
features of what
online education may offer us.
The economic model, we're
still feeling our way.
What's the business model?
How are these cost centers
going to justify themselves?
We're not there yet, but it
looks like this certificate,
micro master's kind of stuff is
probably a good way to do this.
Lifelong learning may be
another very good way to do it.
Will universities be willing?
In other words, we're
sort of at a situation
now where universities
offer a bunch of MOOCs
over on one side, purely online.
And then they're running
their same old university
with lecture classes.
And nothing really changes.
Because as we've discussed,
the blended model
is what's key to the reform,
because that will drive
a new kind of classroom,
the kind of cultural change
you're talking
about, Steph, right?
It could be a driver for this.
So unless universities are
willing to really think hard
about the blended model, then
we won't get the revolution
that we really need, a kind of
transformation of what goes on
in the classroom, and
then full utilization
of this whole new tool set
that gives us essentially
information and content access.
So we're still going
to need-- and the term,
think you were looking for,
Steph, in your argument,
and it's a term that we
use in the legacy sector
analysis, who are the
change agents going to be?
How are we going to
drive change here?
And then that gets us
into our next reading.
MARTIN: Well, but you'd also
change the university business
model.
Because I know when I was
on the executive board
for my fraternity,
we were looking
at a lot of internal
reports for MIT.
And they make a lot more
money off of grad students
than undergrads usually.
So potentially becoming
more of-- because MIT
is pretty much just a
research institution.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
MIT provides huge subsidies
to graduate students in a
massive system of fellowship.
So they're not paying tuition.
MARTIN: But they
end up doing a lot
of prolific work that MIT is
known for and research studies.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: In term
of the research side, yes.
MARTIN: What is the
output of the institute?
So ideally-- or the way
I've seen it usually is--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yes, research output,
graduate students are core.
But tuition, believe me,
undergraduates are key.
MARTIN: But I feel like a better
business model would probably
be getting government
funding for certain research
that has to happen
for the government
or something like that.
I mean, you get a lot
more money that way.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
We'll see.
I'm not yet clear
who is going to drive
this revolution of blended
learning education model.
MIT is now exploring it.
I mean, there's over
90 online classes.
And over 90% of MIT students--
you all can tell me this is
true--
according to my friend Sanjay
Sarma, VP for online learning,
Sanjay says 90% of
undergraduate students
now have a blended
learning experience
in their undergraduate careers.
Does that sound
right to you all?
OK, I'm reassured.
Let me try to lay
out, and then we'll
have 20 minutes
plus for discussion.
The authors of this 2016
report on learning science
were Sanjay Sarma, Karen
Willcox at AeroAstro,
Eric Klopfer, who
I mentioned before,
Philip Lippel in my
office in Washington.
The new online platforms,
as I said a little earlier,
came out of computer
science departments,
because they saw these
incredible broadband access
opportunities.
And believe me, they were real.
I was in Egypt about
four years ago teaching
at the American University
of Cairo for about 10 days
or participating in
programs there lecturing.
And I realized that the
availability of these things
is a complete
worldwide phenomena.
And I asked my Egyptian friends,
how many people in your country
do you think have
access to an iPhone?
They thought about it,
and they said, well,
you know, between friends and
neighbors and connections,
we probably have well over 80%
of our population with access
to iPhones.
So in other words, this is a
pretty poor developing country.
That's an astonishing
access system.
That's an amazing access system.
There's a whole new
delivery vehicle out there.
And the computer
science departments,
logically, saw that first.
So they realized
there was a new tool,
and they raced to create
content to do that, largely just
videoing classrooms, right?
And what this group
felt was, look,
we better figure out how to
optimize the online education
pieces that we're now doing.
How do we understand what's been
happening in cognitive science
and learning science, which
comes out of the education
side, and the neuroscience,
and take advantage
of what they've been learning
about learning in the last 15
years and try and embed
those capabilities
for better learning
into our online courses?
It was a great aim, because
the MOOC development community
hadn't frankly, seriously,
in an organized way,
thought about this.
So this report made
a real contribution.
And there's now a whole
research community.
And I attended their annual
meeting last month at MIT.
And it was a community
from all over the world.
Universities from
everywhere were present.
It was fascinating.
So there were four
key recommendations.
Integrate learning
science from education
with cognitive science
and neuroscience.
These are disciplinary
communities
that never talk to each other,
that are in no communication.
They're coming up with
significant territories,
and there could be a lot
of benefit from crossover.
So that was one of the points.
Optimally structured
online courses and modules
can be an important facilitator
for higher education, emphasis
on optimally structured.
So there are all
these phenomena.
And this report
looked at a number
of the phenomena that affect
learning, like mind wandering,
segmenting learning into more
bite-sized, understandable,
manageable pieces.
Retrieval learning--
in other words,
what's the right mix
between study and test--
the reinforcement mechanism.
How do you do space retrieval?
In other words,
recovery of information
over an extended period of time.
How do you optimize that?
What's the role of curiosity?
Can you use that as a driver
in the learning space?
So they began to look at all
of these phenomena, which
have actually been studied
in a number of these fields,
and attempted to
incorporate them in.
I'm not going to try to
wander through each one
of these elements.
But here's some
of the literature.
And the MRI scans show
you mind wandering.
I mean, different
parts of the brain
are zipping around the
different territories.
And it's a phenomena that
needs to be accounted for.
It's a very natural phenomena.
Mind wandering is--
it's Darwinian.
It's very important for
our minds to wander.
If we're able to
completely stay on topic,
the saber-toothed
tiger would probably
leap through our thatched
cottage and finish us off.
We've got to be
keeping an eye out
for the saber-toothed tiger.
So this is very Darwinian.
It's an important skill to have
mind wandering and the ability
to move from topic
and area to area.
It's an important part of
the creativity of the brain.
But it's been
viewed, historically,
as an enemy of learning.
Teachers want
students on the task
for that full time of
the classroom experience
and are worried when
they get distracted.
So how do you do this?
One approach is to
segment learning
into bite-sized pieces.
So we attempt to do a
bit of that in this class
with 10, 15 minutes of talking
head, i.e. me, and then turning
the discussion over to you all.
So that you've got
varying things occurring,
and you never have much
more than 10 or 15 minutes.
And it probably
should be 8 to 10,
frankly, on a single presenter.
And then you move
to attempt to absorb
the material in the
discussion and have
folks who were presenters
of that material
develop the content themselves.
SPEAKER 2: What is that graph?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Hmm?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You
know, it doesn't quite
match exactly what I was
attempting to show to you.
But it does attempt to show a
tutorial versus a lecture model
and what the median time
frame is in any given limit.
So in a tutorial,
one-on-one setting,
you can see that there's more
focus on topic over an extended
period of time.
Whereas your median point starts
to switch in a lecture model
and gets shorter.
So frankly, tutorials
are a better way
of learning than a lecture.
But it's a fairly
unaffordable model.
Another lesson--
retrieval learning.
The study-study--
in other words,
you study and then
you study, right?
You study and you study it again
versus you study and then take
a test about it.
And over what period of
time, which works best?
So if I was imposing this graph,
we'd have a test every week,
just so you know.
I'm sparing you.
But that would be
the optimal model.
This is one week retention--
study-study, 42% retention,
56% versus study-test.
In the words, being forced
to regurgitate and focus
on the material definitely
does serve a learning purpose.
Curiosity does make a
difference-- in other words,
if you can bring
curiosity into the game.
And there's something famous in
education called an Ebbinghaus
Curve, the forgetting curve.
In other words, people forget.
After about a
week, it's history.
And maybe after a month you
remember some vague outline.
So there's a profound forgetting
curve in the human mind.
And can you do spaced
retrieval to try and change
that curve to retain it longer?
These are all fundamental
issues in learning
that this report attempted
to start to grapple with,
as you saw.
Recommendations
three and four were
to support the profession
of learning engineer.
So MIT got into this
situation where, first of all,
there's a lot of faculty
resistance on every faculty
of these online courses,
because the faculty is thinking,
this stuff's going to
put me out of business,
they're going to
take away my job.
So there's always a lot
of anger, frustration,
and resentment when the
online course arrives.
So MIT very cleverly
attempted to get
some of its top-noted teachers
to take on online courses.
In other words, if the most
respected of your peers
are doing these online
courses, how can you complain?
That was a model here.
And they were able to
do it on the sales point
to the faculty member that,
hey, how many people have you
taught in your lifetime at MIT?
A few thousand?
Your first course is
going to have 30,000,
so you're going to be famous.
That was the sales pitch.
That's an attractive pitch.
So MIT got its senior faculty
and most respected faculty
teaching the early suite
of a lot of these courses.
And that was interesting.
And then they had this
experience, right?
They gave their best
lectures, and then
they built in all
this assessment
and the 10-minute rule
and all this kind of stuff
into the class, and they had to
completely redo their lectures
to fit all the requirements that
Sanjay Sarma and the edX team
was forcing on them.
So they had to rewrite
all their lectures
to fit the new formatting.
And then they gave their
course and they put it online,
which, of course,
every student can take.
So then they go back to
the regular semester,
they're giving their lecture
class, no one shows up.
They've all taken the
class online already.
Why are they going to show up?
So then the faculty
member realized,
I'm going to get
zero attendance here
unless I develop a completely
different kind of content.
So then the faculty
members started
to, in interesting
kind of ways, rethink
what the content was going to
be in the actual face-to-face
classroom.
That's not easy for
a faculty member who
has never looked at
learning science problems
or studied MOOCs and
studied the technology.
So MIT began equipping
them with graduate students
were really interested
in this stuff, who
wanted to use it in their
own teaching experiences
and decided to dig in, realizing
they would be better teachers
and potentially more
saleable if they
had this kind of background.
So these what MIT called
"learning engineers"
were assigned to
the faculty member.
Now, the faculty member
was willing to accept
the graduate student,
if the graduate student
was studying in their field.
In other words, they
respected the graduate student
for having mastered the
professor's own territory.
They weren't
interested in having
graduate students,
know-it-alls, trying
to dictate to them from a
totally different field.
But they were prepared to
accept the graduate student,
if the graduate student
had already shown mastery
of their own fields.
That was respected learning.
So that was another piece
in this learning engineer
experience at MIT.
And it's worked, so we
created this whole community
of graduate students.
When we talk about how to
bring about the revolution,
a whole bunch of graduate
students now at MIT
are getting experience
as learning engineers,
helping these ossified
faculty members,
like me, learn how to
do this fancy MOOC,
online, blended
learning, change around
your face-to-face
classroom, optimized
learning experience stuff.
And that's, you know, these
are all change models.
These are all
potential ways in which
change agents can operate.
But there's a very
deep question about,
how do we do a change model
within a higher education
legacy sector?
Because it's a very
decentralized system.
And MIT's learning lessons,
and other universities
that are doing this
are learning lessons.
But how do we
exchange these lessons
and get these lessons adopted
through the community?
That's a tough assignment.
That's where all of Steph's
points about her implication
was, how do we get change agents
willing to step up to the plate
drive this stuff?
STEPH: And get them respected,
as you've just noted.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
All right.
We've got 20 minutes
for Q&A. Lily, it's you.
LILY: That's me.
I will start-- which one would
you like me to start with?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Whichever one you prefer.
LILY: Hmm, that's tough.
OK.
Let's start-- we ending with
the MITx online learning,
so let's go to that
paper and discuss it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: OK.
LILY: A couple of people had
questions, including myself,
as to what subject areas the
online or blended learning
could be--
or what subject areas could
readily adapt those practices,
and if it's just impossible
to really implement
this sort of style in
some subject areas.
So, for example,
I would not have
wanted to take this course
if it was an online course.
I don't have a
three-hour attention
span sitting at my computer.
And I wouldn't have--
sure, you could have
a discussion group,
and everyone tunes in
on their own devices,
and so you could have this
pseudo-interactive discussion.
But there is just something
about sitting around a seminar
table and interacting
with other humans, for me.
So I wanted to hear what you all
thought about the applicability
of the MITx in certain fields.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I've
always questioned
how either it could be
improved or whether it
is suitable for a lot
of engineering classes,
just from my experience
both as a student,
and then as a TA grading stuff.
So many of the
questions are not just
about getting the right answer.
It's about making
sure you understand
how to approach the problem.
Did you just make one
little mistake along the way
and that gives you
the wrong answer?
A lot of times there's
not even numbers involved.
And so I know they did
solid-state chemistry
as one of the classes that was
first really involved with edX.
And I know the students would
get really frustrated with it,
because they were like, oh,
I rounded this number wrong,
and that's why my answer's
off or all these little things
that edX just wasn't sensitive
enough to pick up on.
And so I don't know if that's
a question of the technology
improving, such that we
have better machine learning
artificial intelligence to
tell what students are doing,
or whether that's just
a limitation that will
be present with this field.
CHLOE: Yeah.
I think building onto that and
from our earlier discussion
about whether teachers
and professors still
have a role in
the very much more
online or automated
education, is
that one of the important
features of being physically
in a classroom or
interacting with a TA
like yourself, or with other
students, or with a professor,
is that they're most
important-- even more
valuable skill of theirs,
as opposed to knowing
their material inside and
out, is having the teaching
ability to identify what your
problem is and understand
the student's psychology
and understand the learning
process.
They can't just point at your
answer and say, this is wrong,
because you did this, but
understand why you're wrong
and then redirect you and
then course correct you.
So I think that will always be
an important element of a truly
well-rounded
education, and you only
get that from interacting
with other people.
KEVIN: I do think that
technology as a sense now,
the face-to-face component, is
critical in a lot of learning,
especially in a class
like this, right?
But what's to say 5,
10, 20 years from now
we can't all just slap
a pair of VR goggles on,
and then we're sitting
in a simulated room,
and then Bill doesn't need
to fly in for every lecture.
[LAUGHTER]
You get that same experience--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Great idea, Kevin.
--how we market it.
And you get the same
experience of sitting around,
but you don't have to leave
your couch or wherever you are.
CHLOE: Yeah, I think that's
allowable and achievable.
But I think--
KEVIN: As it stands now--
CHLOE: Yeah.
We don't have to physically
be in the same room,
but there's still a role
for a human educator
and for human students to
interact with each other.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So far, I
think, Chloe and Kevin, so far,
much of our communication is not
the words that we're mouthing.
It's the expressions we use.
It's eye contact.
It's hand expressions.
There's just a
whole range of stuff
that accompanies what
we're actually saying,
that we use as part of
our communication systems.
And so far, the
technology has not
been precise enough to
enable us to capture
that incredible depth
that face-to-face allows.
And to some extent,
it's frustrating.
In other words, because that
mix of non-spoken communication
skills doesn't get
fully picked up,
people are frustrated
by the experience.
This is a notorious problem
in conference calls,
even in video
conference calls, right?
People don't quite see
what the other person
is driving at or
trying to communicate,
because this raft of other
kinds of communication
is not picked up.
Now, that's not to say that
this won't get a lot better.
And we've obviously moved
to a whole new level
of high definition and a
lot of different machinery.
So it may well get better.
At the moment, it's
not good enough yet
to substitute for
being next to you.
MARTIN: But I'd add
an addendum, though.
Because we're kind
of seeing how,
oh, it's not how
the original is.
But form follows function.
And because it has
a different form,
you have other functions
that we wouldn't have here.
So if it's all online,
then other people
can be telling me
what they got wrong
or I can get recommendations.
But the thing is the system
hasn't been perfected as well.
Or like you said, you
don't want to stay
in a three-hour lecture.
I usually watch videos at
3x if they're educational,
and I'll just go through the
content, go back and forth.
That's why I talk about it.
Because it was like, yo, yo, OK.
But I'd get a lot more
done, and I'd just
focus on the stuff I want to do.
So there's new
functions you can do.
Another really
important aspect that I
thought of from an
organizational standpoint
is, in this class,
certain people
are going to talk up more.
And other people that
might be more shy
might not want to say something.
So that's why you got people
that online are talking heads,
but physically won't say a word.
So that adds new dynamics.
And depending on
the personalities,
other people can excel, right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's why
I try to make some of you--
all of you-- be
discussion leaders a lot
in the course of this semester.
MARTIN: I mean, the issue also
is racism, equity, sexism.
Like if you don't know the
gender or the background
of a person, you only judge
them based on the ideas.
Or the content of
their character
isn't a layer that you get.
CHLOE: I think-- sorry,
were you still expanding?
MARTIN: Well, I
was going to make
a point of so that allows
other people to lead
or excel in this setting.
CHLOE: Yeah.
I mean, there's two
sides to every coin.
So I agree, the
anonymity advantagement
could definitely be a huge plus.
But, I mean, when you have
people trolling your classes,
that's just as quickly--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARTIN: So the thing is, the
post is like Piazza, right?
Your posts can be anonymous,
but the instructors
know who you are.
And I think--
[LAUGHTER]
So they can just
say, oh, please,
or they'll just kick you out.
CHLOE: True.
MARTIN: And that's very like
an 80-20 parental principle
where--
I mean, I don't think everyone's
going to just start trolling
unless it becomes a thing.
But it's an interesting dynamic.
LILY: Yeah, Matt?
MATT: I think even if we
got to the point where
the technology--
well, [INAUDIBLE]..
Even if we got to
the point where
the technology was perfect
and we could simulate
being in this class
together, I think
there's still a lot of value in
the fact that on my way home,
I'll pass by the MechE lounge,
and I'll talk to someone
about their next startup idea.
Just like when we talked about
decentralizing manufacturing,
there's a lot of
know-how and innovation
capability embodied
in just having
things together physically.
But also with the whole
blended learning model,
I don't think
anyone's really trying
to say that we're going to throw
away face-to-face interaction
or anything like that.
And then back to your
original point about,
what does online learning
work really well for?
I think right now my experience
has been it works pretty well,
or it's always better for
quantitative kind of classes.
But I've been working
over the last semester
and setting up an
undergraduate law class here.
And one of the initiatives is
putting on a lot of the content
online.
And what we found that the
MOOC format allows us to do
is give maybe some of
the instructional video
in bite-sized pieces
online beforehand,
and it opens a lot
of in-class time
to actually do a case discussion
and opens up new opportunities
there.
LILY: OK.
STEPH: Oh, I was actually
going to add to yours.
I participated in the
Europe and STS for a year
with a professor named Louis
Bucciarelli, who started off
in mechanical engineering,
has a PhD also
in science, technology,
and society, I
think at the same time.
And he talked for a long time,
I think in AeroAstro, as well.
So he's a very storied
professional emeritus now.
And he's starting
a program called
Liberal Studies in Engineering.
And one of the
challenges that we
had when producing
modules for the program
is that although it did have
the quantitative components
that you're saying that I think
are pretty easy to communicate,
there was a lot of nuances
behind the materials
that we had selected that made
it really complicated for us
to convey both the content and
to then ask questions about it.
And I think one of the examples
that most stood out to me
was when we were doing
a module on wells,
and specifically implementing
wells in the developing world
in the community of Tanzania.
There is a drawing
of a well that
had been built I think in
the 16th or 17th century
that he had scanned and
put into the module.
But it was not--
the mechanism by which the water
was pulled up from the ground
was not very clear,
and the piston just
was not very well-drawn.
And that prevented a lot of--
I was the one who was writing
a lot of the material,
and it was then sent to me,
and then I had to do it.
And then I had to
give him feedback
on my process of doing it.
And it prevented a
lot of my ability
to actually do the problems.
So I think that's one of the
really interesting things
about MOOCs as well, and
especially multidisciplinary
MOOCs, that there are so many
nuances behind the material,
that even if the content seems
fairly straightforward, if you
have no way to
interact-- or rather,
if you don't have
an immediate way
to interact with
the instructor, it
does add an extra
layer of complication
in your ability to
solve something.
And I think that that's
precisely why we benefit
from the blended model, because
then you can come to class
and say, hey,
professor, you uploaded
this image in the problem
set, and I have no idea how
the piston actually operates.
Could you explain this
to me more thoroughly?
Or could you redraw
it and reupload it?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So part
of the motivation, by the way,
for filming this class is for
us to think about whether or not
we take more of the
lectures segments online
and then have even more
of an organized discussion
focus in that
face-to-face classroom.
So part of the
reason of the filming
here is to create
an online course.
But it's also possible
to use this for more
of a blended model here.
LILY: So I wanted to
come bring something up
that Bill mentioned
earlier, which I think
will also transition us into the
Bonvillian and Weiss reading.
Bill mentioned graduate
programs online.
So you complete a year-long
certificate sort of program,
and then can complete the
remainder of your graduate work
on site.
I think that's a really
interesting model and idea,
so I could see that working
well for things like--
well, first of all--
I could see that
working well for things
like maybe business,
engineering, computer
science, et cetera.
And those graduate programs
are typically quite expensive
and can be two to three years.
And unlike a lot of PhD
programs or science programs,
it's not paid for.
So we're talking maybe $50,000
a year for two to three years.
Which brings me
to something that
came up in Bill's reading, which
is student loans and increasing
levels of student loans.
And I was doing a
little bit of research.
Does anyone have any idea what
the current outstanding student
loan debt is in the US?
SPEAKER 2: Isn't
there trillions?
MARTIN: Easily in the trillions.
LILY: Yeah, $1.5 trillion.
[LAUGHS] And they're
not collateralized
and the default
rates are increasing.
SPEAKER 2: Wait, they are?
Last I heard, I
thought they were down.
LILY: Not according to
the 2017 statistics.
SPEAKER 2: Crap.
What I heard was in 2016, so--
[LAUGHTER]
LILY: So with that
in mind, could
the master's program blended
online, then concatenated
or shorthand on-site learning,
improve the situation
with student loan
debt, while still
qualifying the person
with a graduate degree?
SPEAKER 1: I would
just be curious
what the breakdown is
between different fields.
Because I know for MBAs and
law schools, so much of it
is building your network
while you're there.
So people are willing to
take on hundreds of thousands
of dollars in loans just to
have connections to the Harvard
community or whatever.
So if that is only a small
section of the total loans that
are outstanding, then I think
this could be impactful.
But if that's outweighing it--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm not
worried about that class
repaying the loans.
They're OK.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: But that
would still be considered
part of the statistic, right?
Because the first year out, they
might owe $300,000 in loans.
And while they are
paying it back,
I think they would still
be willing to take out
$300,000 of loans regardless
of new technologies.
STEPH: This also assumes the
goodness of the programs that
are putting out these courses.
There's a lot of, I
think, predatory--
what is the name of
the one that just
got shut down that was really
bad, the University of Phoenix?
SPEAKER 1: It's
called The University.
LILY: That's the one.
[LAUGHS]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEPH: Yeah, it sort of
presumes the goodness
of a lot of these organizations.
MARTIN: Well, yeah,
we're assuming
they're all elite
ones, where it's like,
we're sure you're going to
get something [INAUDIBLE]..
STEPH: Yeah, exactly.
And it also presumes
that they're useful,
like there's an instrumentality
or a utility coefficient
that you gain from having
participated in these courses.
And I don't know if the
return on investment
is going to be good for
someone who doesn't already
have a foundational
degree in something.
It assumes that
the job market is
willing to accept
the people who are
graduating with this knowledge.
And I don't know if
that's true right now.
LILY: There's a
really good breakdown
on four-year universities,
by the way, not just
graduate programs.
So, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, Lily, do you
want to make a closing set
of points about these two
readings?
LILY: Yeah.
Pay off your student loans and
don't default on them or else
our entire economy can collapse.
SPEAKER 2: Again?
LILY: Again.
Well, these are the kinds
of numbers-- you know,
there's a critical default
number, just as with
the housing market.
SPEAKER 2: All right, so
we need to all buy shorts--
[LAUGHTER]
LILY: I don't know, how do
you short something that's
not collateralized?
MARTIN: There's a whole thing
about-- yeah, this being
a bubble, the education bubble.
I read a big thing
about Peter Thiel
since we brought him
up in the first class.
RASHID: I think my
favorite example
is there's federally
subsidized student loans.
And if you get clever, you can
use your federally subsidized
student loans to invest
properly, and then
flip those, because those
are inherently safer.
So even if you don't want to--
I should say, there
are a lot of options
to pay back your student loans.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, Lily, bring us
to a couple of key conclusions
about the two readings.
LILY: Conclusions, let's see.
Let me go to my notes.
I think, in general,
the readings
led us to believe that
online learning, or at least
blended learning, is
going to increase in usage
or popularity, whether the
institutions, the universities,
like it or not.
And I don't know.
I think I covered everything
else that I had thought of.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Good.
Let me do just a quick wrap up.
Freeman taught us
about the talent base
and how it's going to
affect the innovation system
and made us aware of the
fact that the SNT talent
base is going to be a
pretty key component of US
overall comparative advantage,
as other people move
to copy the model.
Romer's core point was that
government policy is focused
really on a capital supply
and really on the demand
side of the equation, right?
And that the talent
supply system really
was not a particularly
significant federal government
focus.
It probably needs to be, because
that's a very important factor
in innovation, as
we've discussed earlier
with his prospector theory.
And then he drove us to look at
higher educational institutions
and how they don't get the
economic signaling that
would lead them to
increase the supply.
And he helped us think about
what some of the barriers were
and how you could
change that economic
signaling to change the way
in which the higher education
system dealt with the
supply kit question.
Katz and Goldin taught
us about the tie
between the
ever-increasing technology
requirements of the economy.
Since the Industrial Revolution,
we've been on a rising curve,
and it may be accelerating.
And then they
demonstrated for us
how important it is to keep
the education curve, the talent
base, ahead of that curve,
playing off of that curve.
If you let them cross, like
we did in the 1970s, then
you start to drive
towards pretty serious
economic inequality
problems, because you're
leaving a large part of
your population behind,
unable to get back on
that rising parallel
and stay up with
the technology curve
and earn the
corresponding incomes.
Bamol alerted us to
the fact that education
for invention and
innovation, by the way,
looks different than standard
education systems in science
and technology today,
which are more geared,
historically, towards
incremental advances.
MIT's Online
Education Report got
us thinking about
learning science,
how you could apply learning
science to really optimize
both the online model and
the blended learning model.
And then the reading
from the textbook
showed us a set
of the challenges
for online education, how it's
a potentially disruptive tool
in a legacy sector
education system,
and got us thinking about,
who are the change agents that
might really drive the optimal
model, which is really probably
a blended learning model.